welcome to Hannity buckle up tonight
hope of a possible treatment now exists
it appears very very real we will have a
big report and as always we will bring
you facts without fear without hysteria
without panic we're the United States of
America
land of the free home of the brave
they're not just words also tonight vice
president pence will be joining us and
we'll hear from a covert 19 patient who
says his life was saved he was on
literally at death's door his doctor
said there's nothing else that they can
do he said goodbye to his family then he
was treated with an anti-malaria drug
called Hydra chloroquine truly
miraculous recovery
so are we close to a treatment that may
potentially save thousands and thousands
of lives we will investigate fully
tonight and a report on how just
repulsive the mob and the media how they
really are
that's all moments away but tonight we
start with the Democratic Party in their
despicable behavior over the weekend
lawmakers both sides of the aisle they
hammered out a trillion dollar emergency
spending bill that legislation proposed
billions of dollars let's see for
workers for small businesses for a
struggling big industries like the
airline industry the cruise industry
billions for hospitals and cash payments
to Americans that need it that are
making under ninety nine thousand
dollars a year our fellow Americans are
hurting we rebuilt Europe we saved the
world from evil and tyranny time and
time again now it's time to help out our
American family but what happens
unexpectedly or maybe predictably this
morning Schumer Pelosi torpedo the bill
they are now saying they will not pass
anything that does not include an insane
laundry list of unrelated items nothing
to do with Corona
this is beyond disgraceful I predicted
this would happen so why are they
delaying critical aid financial
assistance to American workers small
businesses large businesses that have
had to shut down look at your screen
this is what they want they want tax
credits for windmills and solar power in
other words they want their green New
Deal one way or the other so they're
willing to deny desperate Americans in
need for this they also want to emit
in mandates for the airline industry
okay mandatory reporting of greenhouse
gas statistics for every airline flight
in other words why don't we just kick
all of you in the teeth that work in the
airline industry when you're down we'll
just kick you right in the teeth
Americans need to put food on the table
pay their rent pay their mortgages their
car payments tell their kids that
they're not gonna have to pull them out
of college where are their priorities
tonight as the nation waits like with
the virus one of the Democrats doing
what were they doing when the president
implemented that critical crucial travel
ban and that critical and crucial
quarantine oh that's right
they were impeaching the president and
forgetful Joe oh he called the president
xenophobic hysterical and a fear
mongerer now as part of some green New
Deal fantasy they're literally trying to
put airline companies out of business
they're going to let Americans live in a
state of anxiety and worry and fear
because they're not doing their job this
is what governments supposed to do serve
the people they're public servants and
that's not all Democrats are also
demanding broad new powers for labor
unions of course they give us all the
money for our elections the forgiveness
of student loan debt new rules
surrounding racial diversity on
corporate boards subsidies for
newspapers and so much more what does
this have to do with people that need
help now now Democratic majority whip
james Clyburn called the quotas
tremendous opportunity to restructure
things to fit our vision small
businesses suffering entire industries
like the restaurant industry are
struggling their workers are losing
their jobs they are afraid they may lose
their homes or get kicked out of their
apartment and what does james Clyburn
agenda he's worried about restructuring
things to fit their radical socialist
vision that is a party the radical
extreme democratic socialist party and
that is them being a national disgrace
again because they've done nothing for
three years anyway they should be
ashamed of this conduct but don't hold
your breath now Democrats for those of
you that have some sense reason
compassion understanding are you
embarrassed about what this party has
become what is your party
Democrat done-for-you in the last three
years to help safety and security peace
and prosperity know 24/7 every minute
second hour of every 24 hour day hate
Trump that's all they've done even
during a time of great urgency when our
fellow Americans need their government
to act they care more about their
radical agenda than helping American
workers small business big business as
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
said Democrats won't let us fund
hospitals or save small businesses
unless they get to dust off the green
New Deal and and and put carbon
footprint it language into this take a
look Democrats won't let us fund
hospitals or save small businesses
unless they get to dust off the green
New Deal are you kidding me this is the
moment to debate new regulations that
have nothing whatsoever to do with this
crisis that's what they're up to over
there American people need to know it
how can half the Senate not rise to the
occasion
at a time when everybody else in the
country is pulling together they're
pulling us apart good for Mitch
McConnell now I can't recall him frankly
being that angry and rightfully so when
Americans need help the most
there's your radical socialists Pelosi
and Schumer they're caring about carbon
footprints and their own political
agenda now that taking a page out of the
political playbook of remember Obama's
chief of staff dead fish Emanuel Rambo
what he did for the people in Chicago
that are getting shot and killed every
weekend for year after year after year
anyway many years ago he said quote you
never let a serious crisis go to waste
it's an opportunity to do things you
could not do before
well guess what Emanuel he's on
state-run conspiracy television MSDN see
where he gave Democrats the exact same
advice take a look as somebody once also
said if we're not I've worked for
President Obama never allow a crisis to
go to waste this will not be our last
epidemic we had h1n1 we had SARS what we
have to ensure and this is where
presidential leadership counts that we
will this will not be the last endemic
but it must be the last economic
depression because of a pandemic and
then start setting out how to use this
crisis to invest in public health
tonight every American is a right to be
angry and ticked off Democrats cannot
for even a second put aside their petty
politics to actually help our fellow
Americans in need this is beyond a
betrayal to every American worker
through people that really make this
country great
those that are struggling now and even
some Democratic members of Congress
maybe a few sensible ones very few
reportedly growing weary of these
disgusting political games but not quid
pro quo dr. Joe that's Joe Biden he's
trying to use the coronavirus to score
cheap political points remember he sent
out his letter fundraising off the virus
when President Trump announced his
travel ban on January 31st oh that was
ten days after the first confirmed case
in the United States
what did Biden say the president's
travel bank warranty was xenophobic
hysteria and fear mongering stands by
that today now Biden is giving the
single most bizarre series of weird
online speeches about how he would be
handling the pandemics so much better
than Donald Trump only problem is
everything he mentions Trump has already
done a long time ago and the things he
wouldn't do may would have made a
difference in the first speech he
seemingly forgot remember that speech is
when he was like oh I forgot him on
doing this let me let me let me and they
had to cover the screen today he lost
his train of thought oh what a shocker
does he even know what day it is by the
way it's not super Thursday struggling
with a teleprompter he's like hurry up I
have nothing to say hurry hurry
watch and and in addition to that in
addition to that we have to make sure
that we we are in a position that we are
well let me let me go the second thing
I've spoken of in it and we need to
build an arsenal of democracy and as we
did in 1940 we can take we can make a
personal productive equipment look
here's the deal we have to do what we
did in the 40s in the 20s then 20 20
oh sorry a lot more on Biden's confusion
and bitterly partisan response to the
pandemic he's too has been disgraceful
here but first okay what do I always say
on this program when I throw to Laura
Ingraham let not your hearts be troubled
we have some amazing prospects on the
horizon news to share so while the
Democrats play political games to score
cheap political points in an extreme
agenda
well the Trump administration and
private businesses are stepping up to
the plate in fact you're now watching
history president Trump is now rewriting
every rule on how not only this country
but the world will deal with future
pandemics things we've never done before
travel bans oh I wonder if that will be
implemented faster next time knowing
what we know now drive up testing
private public partnerships you see the
telemedicine that's coming online
how many emergency room visits could be
stopped if people 2 in the morning can
call a doctor at their avail on their
FaceTime and say my son or daughter has
the croup and making really weird noises
like a seal
and then what do I do well first put
some steam in the shower or do that
first if it doesn't work call me back in
an hour maybe a third maybe more
emergency room visits will end
slashing red tape with the FDA
compassionate care the right to try
testing new treatments of public-private
partnerships every one of these things
is innovative President Trump on every
area setting a new precedent rewriting
the books as we watch as we speak how
many Americans would have contracted
this virus but for the travel ban and a
quarantine that one decision 10 days
after the first known case in this
country that was January 31st first
known case January 21st
how many more may have died moving
forward with these new rules the new
book he's writing in front of us how
many lives will potentially be saved in
the future America's private businesses
are also to their great credit you know
you listen to the Liberals they often
trash Walmart we're smelling a Walmart
Trump supporters I always say yeah I
love Walmart I love Target I love see me
yes I love Walgreens Walmart mall
look at this all of these companies
and even companies I'm not that fond of
Google Facebook 3m all of them deserve
credit tonight donating space money
energy and assistance in any way they
can
helping to get the products to those in
need look at GM look at Ford say oh we
can make ventilators you need something
we here keep reading that we might not
have enough some of America's top
hospitals and manufacturing their own
protective gear that's why I said at one
point we will ultimately probably here
save the world again how many times is
America come to the rescue
best medical research of scientists
doctors nurses and medical professionals
in the entire world we keep the world
free we bail out and rebuild Europe we
beat fascism Nazism communism Imperial
Japan and more recently radical Islamism
Tesla GM Ford America's top
pharmaceutical companies those evil evil
drug companies donating medicine and
working around the clock to help develop
a vaccine never before have we've been
able to break down the sequence of a
virus used to take years we did it in
what five six weeks and get and we now
have first trial potential hopefully
vaccines in the process and get this
several big businesses are hiring
massive amounts of people thousands of
new job postings at Amazon and 7-eleven
and Walmart
I think Walmart said they're hiring
150,000 people maybe you need a bridge
job but till you get your job back by
the way I put the list fully up on
Hannity comm other Walgreens are
offering bonuses along with Walmart to
their employees part-time and full-time
many big-box stores are now offering to
pay raises and double overtime this is
what we as Americans do this is who we
are we come together we help one another
in a time of need nobody saw this coming
anyone that says they saw coming is full
of it because they didn't we all work
hard we all find solution solutions were
innovative we're creative we are the
United States of America the greatest
country God gave man we're blessed to
live here yes one nation well you know
we're endowed by a thing a thing that's
you know oh the thing God that creates
everything speaking of which US doctors
and scientists this is the big news
tonight
they are seeing success with new
treatments experimental treatments on my
radio program one of those doctors
detailed is very important progress
here's what he said you've had a hundred
percent success rate I define success as
not having to go to the hospitals and
hospitals overwhelmed right now
so I've treated the gressive leave these
patients and I've seen remarkable
results within the shortness of breath
tissue resolves within four to six hours
now this doctor published that he and
his well team have now treated patients
with that regimen none of them died none
of them were hospitalized
he now has 350 case test cases that he's
referring to now similar methods are now
being tested all over the world for
example researchers in France they have
released a preliminary study showing how
a combination hydroxy chloroquine and
antibiotics could be used to mitigate
symptoms of those impacted with the
virus and heal them quicker and one more
good piece of information we learned
today at the president's press
conference with his taskforce that young
people thankfully are not dying of
coronavirus of prominent Nobel laureate
biophysicist from Stanford med modeled
the outbreak and is now predicting that
a fairly quick end to this pandemic and
he predicted accurately everything that
was going to happen in China and we have
more good news as of March 18th there
have been zero fatalities from children
and only one death of one teenager
worldwide we get nervous based on the
new numbers first we were told up until
about a week ago that it wasn't
impacting kids that we here it is that
makes it more scary that is good news
tonight this is a serious disease as I
said Oh January 27th got to take it
seriously but we're going to get
strategic and we're going to find
solutions you can't panic now we have
more good news coming up and more facts
without fear